[音楽]
ん
みなさんこんにちは
ba ぶちゅーどねー
子どもたちを信じる素晴らしい言葉です
私は最近になってこの言葉の意味を意識するようになりました
それまでは子どもを信じるということよりも自分の授業をどうするか
そういうことばかり考えていましたいい授業をしたい
でもどうしても勉強についてこれない子
勉強わからない子かいう
そんな子たちのため
勉強がわかるようにするために私は考えました
先輩に聞いたり教育の方を選んである
ある時博多駅の本屋でウロウロしているととても良い方を見つけたんです
その本に公開でありました
子どもたちを信じましょう
それから私の教師としての人生が始まりました
私の人生も変わりました
子どもたちの人生も変わりました
私のこれが believe 中どれんです
皆さんは授業と聞いてどのようなものを想像しますか
おそらくこのように先生が前に立って
子どもたちが席について
ノートを取ったり先生の話を聞いたりするのが一般的かと思います
私も最初教師になった時にこのように授業を行っていました
一生懸命授業をしていたので子どもたちの多くは先生
とてもわかりやすいよそう言ってくれたんです
でも中にはどうしても勉強についてこれない子
勉強が分からない子がいました
そんな子たちのために休み時間や放課後一緒に勉強しました
その時子どもたちは
先生わかったよそういう風に言うんです
でもテストをしてみるとやっぱりよく分かってなかったっ
どうすればいいか私は一生懸命考えました
やはり自分の授業をもっと分かりやすくするしかない
こう考えたんです
自分の授業一生懸命しようとするほどこのような言葉が増えてきます
勉強しなさ
宿題をしなさい話を聞きなさい
でもうまくいかないです
どうしても勉強についてこれない子がいました
そんな思いで何とかしたいと思っていた時に
先ほどの方に出会いました
その方に変えてあった授業のスタイルがこのような授業です
ご覧のように
ペアで勉強したりし5人のグループで勉強したり
一人で勉強していると思います
このような授業のスタイル学び合いと言います
20カギ括弧がついています
どのように授業をするかというと
たとえば算数の教科書39ページこの問題を
ゲームわかるようになるという子供に課題を出します
そして子どもたちにこう言うんです
自由に歩き回って自由に教えやっていいよその代わり
一つだけ約束があるんだ
店員がわかるようになってね
さあどうぞ
そう言って任せるんです
意外と子供たちはすぐい教え合ったり説明し合ったりするようになります
しかし何日か続けていくと
こんなことがありました
教室の端のほうで
消しゴムを投げ合ったりっ
前の日のテレビの話をしたりそんな子が出てきたんです
私はそんな姿を見ながらどういうふうに声を掛けようか悩みました
みなさんならどのように声をかけますか
おそらく勉強しなさいと
真面目にやりなさい
そういうふうに言ってしまうんじゃないでしょうか
でも私はそう言いませんでした
あの言葉が忘れられなかったからです
任せて信じて待ちましょう
子どもたちを任せて待ちましょう
私は待ちました
するとこんなことがあったんです
いつものように遊んでる子に対して他の子が
ね
わからないから教えてっ
すると遊んでいる子はわかった教えるよといって一緒に勉強するようになったんです
私はとても驚きました
それから子どもたちのことをよくよく見ているとこんな言葉が聞こえるようになったん
です
分からない人いない
ねえ教えてよ
分かってありがとう
私が授業をしていた頃にはこんな言葉が聞けませんでした
もしかしたらこの学び合いという授業は子どもたちにとってとても良い授業なんじゃ
ないか
そう思うようになったんです
さあ
学び合いという授業今御説明しましたけれども
いげんしが沸いたでしょうか
実際に見てみたくないですか
ご覧いただきましょうどうぞ
はっはっは
[拍手]
た
よっ
彼らはですね私が小学校彼らから小学校6年生の時に担任をした子達で今
中学校2年生の生徒達ですこの日のために集まってくれました
実際にわからん
問題を解いてもらいたいと思います
久しぶりですけど
いけそうですかねぇ
だそこの机などを使って初めてください
さあどんな問題を出しているか
[音楽]
生徒たちはこのような問題を解いていますには缶を開けますか
急に出されて
困るんじゃないでしょうか
[音楽]
彼らは小学校6年生の時にこのような授業を毎日毎日していました
今数学の問題なんですけれど国語とか社会とか色々な科目で毎日を行っています
教えてますよね
私は何も教えたりしません
どこっ
[音楽]
クロード説明しあっていいですよ
ちなみに解き方が結構あるんですよこれ
[音楽]
わかんない
ああああああ
ほっ品
んをっ
解き方が違いますね色々と
こっちは違いますねぇ
んですよねん
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
持っています
安全ヶ月だここは仕事
3-3
[音楽]
ね ok ok みんな ok
ができたばっちりじゃあ答えを生の
パーフェクトですありがとうございます
ありがとうございますが少しこのあたりで待っててもらっていいです
me
このように彼ら今数学の問題を解いてもらいましたが先ほども言ったように
国語とか色々な教科で行うことができます
私はそう学校の教員ですけれど中学校や高校で同じように授業をしている方もたくさん
いらっしゃいます
本当にこんな授業で勉強分かるようになるの
そう思いませんか
実は彼らが小学校6年生の時に全員がテストで90点以上取りました
勉強が苦手だったそういったこの全員です
私が今担任をしているクラス昨年投入をしていた子達も全員90点以上取りました
つまり
子供同士で教えたほうがわかりやすいですね
わかるようになるんですそれを私はわかることができました
しかし今日皆さんにお話をしたいのは
90点以上を奪ったそういうことだけではありません
助け合い支え合って
いやば1人も見捨てられ仲間になったということです
困った時わからない問題があった時に教えてと言える仲間がいる
困ったときに大丈夫と言ってくれる仲間がいる
安心感があって自分の居場所があって
温かい繋がりのあるそんな半ばになる
本当に素晴らしいことだと私は思います
彼らからそういうことを学んで自分の自身の人生でもたくさんの人に支えられて助け
られてきたんだ
そういうことを思うようになりました
そして今自分の身のまわりにある人のつながり
家族や友人そして職場の仲間たち
そんなつながりも大事にしたいそのように思うようになりました
こんな温かい人のつながりを作るために大人ができることは子どもを信じることです
子どもを信じるといってもそう簡単なことではないと私は思います
なぜなら大人は意外と子供のことを信じていないことを無意識に言ってしまったりする
からです
例えば勉強しなさい2付けなさい
高評価こういうことはよく言うと思うんですただ
勉強しなかったら
おやつあげないよとか
片付けなかったら
テレビ見ちゃダメだよこういうことを言ってしまいがちなんです
私もそうでした
だから
自分の言葉や行動が本当に子供のことを信じているのか
いつもいつも見直すようにしてそういうことの繰り返しで少しずつ少しずつですが子供
たちのことを信じられるように少しずつなっていたと思います
もちろんまだまだ努力しないといけないことはあります
そして
子供のことを信じて待つということが必要です
子どもたちが目標を持ったりまた大人が目標を持たせたりしたときに
ダン日も何ヶ月でも待つんです
途中うまくいかないこともあるかもしれません裏切られるようなこともあるかもしれ
ません
それでも末ですそうしたら子どもたちが自分の力を発揮してどんどん成長していきます
そんな姿を一緒になって喜んでいけばもっともっと伸びていくんです
先生勉強が分かるようになったよ
友達ができたよ学校が楽しいよ
そんなことを一緒に喜んだ本当に嬉しくないですか
現在の教育現場にはさまざまな課題があります
苦しんでいる子供たちもいます私がその全ての課題を解決したり子どもスコート戸数
ことはできません
でも
子どもを信じることはできます
子どもたちを信じれば
子どもたちのクラスや教室はもっと持って明るくなっていくはずです
そうすれば日本の社会も少しずつですが明るくなるのでないでしょうか
学校が楽しいそんな子どもたちが増えたら世界は変わるのではないでしょうか
その第一歩として子供たちのことを信じる
私はこれが必要だと思います
私はこれからも子供のことを信じる大人って言いたいです
子どもたちの幸せを願えるをとなっていたい
believe 中度年ビリー組ウィリーバース
believe children ありがとうございましたわー
ダービー苦痛の
ああああああ
先生ありがとうございますありがとうどうですか素晴らしい
分
[拍手]